ننتقل الآن إلى الهند حيث
ظهر مقطع فيديو صادم ومصور يظهر
امرأتين تتعرضان لاعتداء جنسي وحشي.
اندلعت الاحتجاجات بعد
إصدار الفيديو. وقد شاهدت شبكة CNN الفيديو ولكن من
الواضح أننا لا نعرضه احترامًا
للناجين من
الهجوم الوحشي.  تقول مجموعة من السكان الأصليين إن
الاعتداء وقع في أوائل شهر مايو في
ولاية مانيبور شمال شرق البلاد، ويُظهر مقطع الفيديو
امرأة مذعورة تُجبر على
المشي عاريات وسط حشد من
الرجال الذين يرتدون ملابس كاملة، ثم تقول المجموعة إنه
تم نقلهن إلى أحد الحقول واغتصابهن جماعيًا، وهو
ادعاء تحت  التحقيق
ينضم إلي الآن من نيودلهي مع المزيد أه
أمريكا أخبرنا بما تستطيع عن هذا
ولكن أيضًا ردود الفعل والغضب
من الفيديو وما يظهره من
[ __ ] وفظيع وصادم
ومزعج للغاية
ومرعب ما هي إلا بعض الكلمات التي
يستخدمها الناس على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  وما
بعد مايكل بعد مشاهدة هذا الفيديو
الذي انتشر على مدار الـ 48 ساعة الماضية،
هناك غضب وطني هنا في الهند
بسبب الفيديو حيث أشرت مثلك بالطبع إلى
أننا لن نعرض هذا
الفيديو لأننا لا نستطيع ولا ينبغي لنا ذلك
لعدة أسباب خاصة
احترم هاتين المرأتين وما
مروا به ولكن هذا ما رأيناه وقد
صدمنا عندما رأينا هذا الفيديو عندما ظهر على
الإنترنت، أُجبرت امرأتان
على المشي عاريتين عبر الشارع،
وكانا محاطين بحشد من الرجال يرتدون
ملابسهم بالكامل  تم الاعتداء على إحدى
النساء وتم صفعها على وجهها بينما قام
رجل آخر بملامستها وتم إجبارها على الدخول
إلى حقل الأرز. هذا الفيديو الذي تبلغ
مدته حوالي 26 ثانية كل إطار منه
يصدمك ويتركك تشعر
بالاشمئزاز والاكتئاب وفقدان الكلمات لرؤية
ما  لقد مروا